PITTSBURGH PENGUINS THAT JUST
WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH HOCKEY FOR
THEAGAINST SCHENN.
>> JOHN: IT IS ROBERT THOMAS
AGAINST LARS ELS A GOALTENDER,
PREPARATION, PROFESSIONALISM AND
WIDE OPEN GOAL?
>> Darren: FEHERVARY MISSED
THREE GAMES BECAUSE OF
OTHER.
AND A BIG STEP-UP HIT BY
SCANDELLA.
>> Darren: I GUESS SO.
GOAL BY LEASON AND MY.
>> JOHN: WIDE OPEN GOAL HOW DID
HE MISIS HEEL OF
THE STICK OF OVECHKIN, HE'S JUST
OFF TO THE SLIGHT RIGHT OF DIFFR
>> JOHN: AND OVECHKIN ON UP BY .
HERE'S HE CAN DO IS DUMP IT  NO
AND FIRES IT AND A
HIM.
>> JOHN: IT'S 1-0 ON THE GOAL BY
RUSH.
>> JOHN: THAT'S WHAT I'M SAYING,
VERY ODD FOR A SHEARY.
WILSON AGAIN IN THE SLOT A SHOT.
NOW KYROU FOR THOMAS.
HE WALKS IN, ANDWA, TONAGO.
AS YOU SAID,BY PARAYKO.
AND ON THE LEFT SIDE OF
THE ICE.
HERE'S THE WAITING,
SHOOTING ONE UP HIGH AND MAYBE
OFF TO THE ZONE AND
OSCAR SUNDQVIST MAKES THE
CAPITALS
O'REILLY LITTLE CHIP BACK IN
PASS, SAAD HIS PADS
DOWN LOW.
MADE TRAINING
STAFF IS.
>> JOHN: THAT HAPPENED IN LIKE
ONE SECOND, BROKEN STICKORN GOE!
AND BARBASHEV APPEARS TO HAVE
BEAT GHT.
>> John:.
>> JOHN: AND THE CAPITALS AS YOU
GOT A BREAK AWAY.
KOSTIN ON HIS KNEES, TO HIS
SKATES ANDITH
HIS LEFT PAD AND NOW
BUCHNEVICH'S SHOT, AND A GLOVE
SAVE
BACKHAND PASS BY BUCHNEVICH WAS
BRILLIANT.
KOSTIN, TRIED TO CUT, AND HE
DOES, A SHOT AND A SAVE PERIOD
WRISTER, I THINK BY JENSEN AS L
BROWN IS A NICE PLAY BY
SUNDQVIST, NOW FOR SAAD, WIDE
OPEN DAVID PERRON A